good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight this is a fox news alert
facing almost certain defeat for his
party in the midterm elections five
months from now joe biden has become
desperate he's decided to leverage the
murder of 19 children in texas last week
for political advantage he just spoke at
some length from the white house about
the need to disarm the population
we're going to spare you all of it we've
taken a few select sound bites that sum
up the president's message here they are
second amendment like all other rights
is not absolute this isn't about taking
to anyone's rights
it's about protecting children
it's about protecting families
it's about protecting whole communities
it's about protecting our freedoms to go
to school
to a grocery store to a church
without being shot and killed we need to
ban assault weapons in high-capacity
magazines
and if we can't ban assault weapons then
we should raise the aids to purchase
them from 18 to 21.
strengthen background checks
enact safe storage law and red flag laws
repeal the immunity that protects gun
manufacturers from liability
address the mental health crisis
deep into the trauma
of gun violence and as a consequence of
that violence
these are
rational common sense measures and if
congress fails
i believe this time a majority of
american people won't give up either
i believe the majority of you will act
so to summarize the president's remarks
tonight your constitutional rights are
not absolute but in taking them away
we're not actually taking away your
rights we're protecting children to
which you might ask am i a threat to
children
that question is never answered by the
president
the point of this of course is to disarm
people who did not vote for joe biden
and that is why simultaneous with this
this effort to re-categorize the guns in
your closet as felonies
democrats have been failing to prosecute
gun crimes in our cities where most of
the crime is
and if you're
at all confused about whether the
effort here is selective if this is
enforcement only at certain people
you'll notice the president never
mentioned the apparent federal gun
felony his own son committed when he
lied on a federal background form when
he bought a handgun
didn't mention that just department has
completely ignored it instead
biden's fellow democrats in the house of
representatives spent the day debating
ways to disarm you americans who've
committed no crime at all and want only
to protect themselves and their families
democrats plan to criminalize possession
of what they're calling large capacity
ammunition feeding devices that is
specifically any magazine that can hold
more than 10 rounds of ammunition well
as it turns out that is most magazines
in the united states tens of millions of
americans right now have so-called
high-capacity magazines in their homes
they're not militia members they're not
gun nuts they're normal people and the
reason they have them is because most
modern handguns and rifles use that type
of magazine the kind that
joe biden is telling you is threatening
and esoteric
and these same firearms the ones in your
house right now will not accept the kind
of diminished magazines joe biden is
demanding you use and that means in
effect all of those guns will be banned
which guns specifically well for example
the glock 19 probably the most popular
handgun in the united states the glock
19 comes from the manufacturer with a 15
round magazine now the glock 19 is not
an especially scary firearm it's a
workmanlike pistol if you have any
interest in guns at all you probably
already own one but under this bill the
glock 19 would be banned illegal a
felony sitting your bedside table and so
had many other popular firearms in the
united states
now this is about saving the children
joe biden just told us but how many
lives would this new law save well we
know the answer zero not one
we know that because there is precisely
no evidence at all and never has been
that larger magazines somehow inspire
mass shootings
but of course saving lives is not the
point of this disarming you is the point
florida congressman greg stooby tried to
explain that at a hearing today of the
house judiciary committee watch how this
unfolded
here's a gun i carry every single day to
protect myself my family my wife my home
comes with a 15 round magazine here's a
seven round magazine which would be less
than what would be lawful under this
bill if this builder would come off it
doesn't fit so this gun would be banned
i hope this gun is not
loaded i'm at my house i can do whatever
i want with my guns
so you heard a voice in the background
greg stubby obviously knows his way
around firearms that was his gun
but off camera you heard sheila jackson
lee of texas interrupting greg stouby to
tell him how to handle a firearm in his
own home so was sheila jackson lee a gun
instructor now what does she know about
firearms well glad you asked sheila
jackson lee is the person who once
explained to us that ar-15s shoot 50
caliber rounds and weigh more than quote
10 boxes
whatever that means
so sheila jackson lee knows literally
nothing about firearms and yet she plans
without shame to regulate them but only
regulate your guns shield jackson lee
has no intention of disarming her own
bodyguards for example or her own
constituents
the democrats bill contains an explicit
exemption for bodyguards even sheila
jackson lee understands the people
protecting her family may need a lot
more than 10 rounds
and most of them carry that as the
washington post put it quote american
law enforcement officers ubiquitously
carry handguns with more than 10 rounds
of ammunition and often more than 15. it
is also why their rifles typically have
20 or 30 round magazines not 10.
now why would sheila jackson lee's
bodyguards need all of those bullets why
would anybody need all of those bullets
as chuck schumer often asks rhetorically
and the answer of course is because it's
a dangerous world and if you're serious
about protecting the people you love you
will be serious about the firearm you
carry
but it turns out we know this for a fact
now democrats are not serious about
protecting you or your family and that's
why they defunded your police and called
you a racist for complaining about it as
your city collapsed
what they care about deeply what they
care about more than anything at all is
protecting themselves and that's why
their bodyguards will continue to get
any kind of magazines they want and what
they want are high capacity magazines
democrats spent the rest of the day
trying to figure out how to ban what joe
biden has called ghost guns ghost guns
they're scary
well several states attorneys have
already tried to ban ghost guns but
every state that has has run into the
same problem
no one can say what a ghost gun is
it's a made-up term it has no meaning as
a judge in nevada put it late last year
when he struck down a ban on so-called
ghost guns quote
nevadans would face the risk of
discriminatory enforcement by police and
prosecutors alike as they in their sole
discretion and without guidance could
label almost anything an unfinished
frame or receiver
if it in any way resembles a firearm's
undefined frame or lower receiver in
other words
any gun could be a ghost gun if
democratic operatives say it is and of
course that's the way they like it
the bill before congress defines ghost
gun as a firearm including certain
firearm parts that does not have a
unique serial number engraved by a
licensed manufacturer
okay
but the question is which part of a
firearm should require engraved serial
numbers that's the question on that
question hangs whether or not your
possession of this object is a felony or
legal
now according to the bill any quote
essential component of the firearm would
require an engraved serial number but
here's the point
merrick garland gets to make the call
this bill grants merrick garland who is
a craven and ruthless partisan we know
that for a fact at this point grants
merrick garland the sole authority to
define what an essential component is
and if merrick garland decides you've
got a quote a central component that
does not have an engraved serial number
you're going to jail
see how this works
so once again the point is not to stop
school shootings there's never been a
school shooting with a so-called ghost
gun
if you were interested in stopping
school shootings and all of us should be
you would take a serious look at why
they happen in the first place what do
the people who commit them have in
common
but no one in congress particularly the
democratic side is doing that
so this isn't an attempt to stop school
shootings it's not an attempt to make
this a safer country
this is exactly what it looks like the
beginning of a plan to confiscate and
criminalize firearms in the hands of the
law-abiding in this country
and if you doubt that no that nancy
pelosi has already announced she's going
to introduce legislation banning
so-called assault weapons next week oh
assault weapons what's an assault weapon
any gun that nancy pelosi's bodyguards
have that you should not be allowed to
have and there's also a new quote red
flag law
in progress now that law would allow the
government to seize firearms from
anybody it wants whether or not they
committed a crime now under a current
system you have to be convicted in order
to be punished but under the red flag
laws if someone doesn't like the cut of
your jib you lose your constitutional
rights
now that's
baldly unconstitutional and you know it
is because democrats are suddenly
talking about packing the supreme court
in order to make it law watch
you will not stop us from advancing the
protecting our kids act today
you will not stop us from passing it in
the house next week and you will not
stop us there
if the filibuster obstructs us
we will abolish it
if the supreme court objects we will
expand it and we will not rest until we
have taken weapons of war out of
circulation in our communities each and
every day we will do whatever it takes
to end gun violence whatever it takes
in our communities really what's the
murder rate in your community pal and
what exactly have you done to make it
better
nothing
monday jones wants power they all do and
to that end he wants to and the
filibuster destroy the entire judiciary
to quote end gun violence
a move like that raises a lot of
questions for example does mondaire
jones have any idea what he's talking
about
like the details because you're a
lawmaker fox's hillary vaughn caught up
with him today she wanted to know what
weapons of war he intends to ban this is
a revealing exchange watch this here's
what he said
you mentioned you want weapons of war
out of circulation what is a weapon of
war to you assault weapons
assault weapons was that like
semi-automatic handguns and rifles
semi-automatic weapons
would qualify as assault weapons and
these are things that should be banned
almost take almost every gun off of out
of people's hands i mean true i mean
handguns for example would not qualify
under under what i just described i got
i'm sorry i gotta go
so yes
monday jones just explained
yeah all semi-automatic weapons which
hillary vaughn says yeah handguns yeah
handguns so you want to take everyone's
handguns away no oh handguns wouldn't
qualify as assault weapons
even though he just defined assault
weapons as any quote semi-automatic
weapon
so clearly mondaire jones knows what
hillary von was trying to tell him that
most firearms in this country including
most handguns are quote semi-automatic
weapons including only 22 calibers
that aren't causing a ton of school
shootings
but when hillary vaughn points this out
mondaire jones runs away and probably
not back to his district to lower the
murder rate he just didn't want to get
into details
so what are we looking at here well
today a guy on twitter called spike
cohen summed it up pretty nicely here's
what he wrote quote the u.s government
has been arming ukraine because they're
allies
the us government has been seeking to
disarm russia because they're opponents
in totally unrelated news the us
government seeks to disarm you
well exactly
that's the framing that's the truth
anyone who tries to disarm you by
definition considers you an enemy
that's what you do to your enemies you
disarm them
your friends your allies your children
people you love why would you want to
prevent them from defending themselves
you never would
you certainly wouldn't scream at them
from the podium about how they're
killing children if they want to protect
their own families that's what you do to
your enemies
and yet somehow
a lot of republicans particularly in
leadership mitch mcconnell specifically
but a lot of others lindsey graham south
carolina don't seem to understand this
or maybe they do
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight